that is the cutest kitten ever
Kiani so kyani was a feature-length
comedy by the comedy duo of key and
Peele keegan-michael key and Jordan
Peele and in this movie Jordan peels
character really doesn't feel like he
has a lot going for him he's really down
on his luck then this little kitten
comes to his door who he names key on it
just why not I would totally named my
cat Keanu or alpha door I would name my
cat alpha door if you get it you get it
if you don't but then someone has broken
into his house and steals his kitten so
now he has to invade this gang who owns
a club the gang's run by Method Man he's
really cool I was like is Method Man yes
how hi I like Method Man I like seeing
him and [ __ ] he was really good in this
movie play all right ner getting ahead
of myself
so they invade and they gotta act really
thug these guys are not thought
whatsoever these guys would not fit in
any they would fit in in the show The
Wire if they were the cops secretaries
copy-machine kids getting doughnuts for
the cops they're clearly faking it and
they got to do a couple of drug run
missions for Method Man's character and
then things go awry and shenanigans and
here we are we have a movie called key
on it first of all key and Peele I'm
gonna call them that because it's in
their names these dudes have great
chemistry together at this point I
suppose they should because they've been
working together for how long
keegan-michael key brings that energy
we've grown to love uh Perry you
remember that crappy pitch perfect to
movie remember how he was the best thing
in the movie he'll is quieter than key
and so key it's easier for him to
eclipse pale I'm calling them just by
their last names now so standing out in
a situation like that is actually quite
difficult and Peele does it very well
and not every joke lands in this movie
for sure there are jokes I was like
that's hysterical there were a couple
parts where I was like that is downright
hysterical well there were some jokes
where I was like alright didn't really
land as much but doesn't matter because
cutest kitten ever no one's gonna
remember the joke that didn't land we're
gonna leave this movie theater going
that scene was funny that seamless fun
oon kitten what I did
I assume that translates and transcends
to other people too but I've come to
know this in screens right i screen this
movie with a theater of about five
people in it and there's a very real
thing about the energy of a crowd of
people in a movie theater who are all
into the movie and they're laughing the
energy is really going and when they
laugh and have a good time you're
laughing and having a good time
everyone's having a good time because
everybody's having a good time it's this
self-sustaining comedy machine energy
inside the movie theater because of the
audience so I feel like if you watch
this movie with a crowd in a movie
theater I feel like you're going to
laugh harder at scenes I didn't laugh as
hard act there's just a whole crowd
thing manage you're all gonna amp each
other up and they will be amped up
because they will probably be high just
say let's just be real about it at this
point there's actually a bit more going
on in this movie than just at surface
level laughter you really understand why
this guy is going after this cat I mean
this dude is a single dude he doesn't
have he doesn't live with anybody he has
no kids he has no wife or you understand
that when these guys steal his cat he's
not going after his pet he's not going
to get his cat back he's going to get
his family back he's going to get his
kid back to him that's how it is and I
really I get that guys in the end Keanu
was funny had great chemistry between
the two leads I was laughing laughing
harder in some scenes than other scenes
but you cannot deny that this comedy duo
really does have it going on I want to
see more movies from them not
necessarily your link to the Keanu
universe is give me more [ __ ] in the end
I walked out of the movie having a good
time and I will say Keanu is a good time
no alcohol or anything else required
right so Keanu have you seen it what did
you think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you liked what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more